if all that means its area okay let's
come back to why shouldn't that one okay
let's come back to something like say
okay
here's a simple breath and I can say
well okay look let's pick an area pick
an area let's say go from over here
that's going to be negative tooth all
the way up until say - okay and I say
well what's this area this area under a
curve right the way out right this is I
would say integral from this boundary to
this boundary negative 2 to 2 of this
particular function that's the function
of interesting that defines this curve
right so I'm going to say X plus 2 and
I'm multiplying by all those little ribs
along there
some time it all I mean is an area from
UTC up under that that's all these right
and this area the shape I made is a
triangle so all I need all I need is
base hi / - right
I've picked a very easy numbers the base
is going to be for the heights gonna be
2 + 2 X 4 right / - so this interval is
an area it's just that's all it means
that's all the leads right that's that's
it write an integral is an area I know
but
okay now we're gonna get to this for now
the important idea is each scenario
right let's start with areas that we
already know how to work out and then we
will progress onto areas we don't know
how to work out okay so yes okay where
do I am let's just retrace this because
this is a critic I'm so badass right
it's a critical pressure not win of DX
first appear on the board anyway on that
graph okay you're first looking here
right because DX just means like D means
change Delta that's right
there's a little little change in X just
like this is a little change in Y okay
why is it not one now because we use
that to indicate a little change in X a
little width we borrow that language to
substitute for this and this which are
very very the two widths right so
there's my little bit there and there's
my height okay
quite times a little win I'm adding up
this series of things that's why it's a
son oh we will
believe me we will baby steps okay now
before I am before I set you loose on
the exercise again let me get across to
you the idea the integration is about
trying to find an area right so anything
you do the area of you know how to
integrate okay because you're taking a
bunch of things use Tory them together
has one hole okay so for instance let's
see how this guy okay okay if I have a
semicircle M that's half of the unit
circle half of the user right what's the
equation of this semicircle I'll give
you hit that starts with y equals
square root of where did I get that from
where I get that from the unit circle
the whole thing which has the top in the
bottom is that guy right if I take the
x-squared over and then by taking the
square root if I want both of them I say
hustle - right the plus is the top and
the minus is the bottom but I just got
the top you happy with that
so how do i number one state and then
number to calculate evaluate the area
under this curve well firstly it's this
integral from when you want to learn of
this function and I'm doing it with
respect to X there's my little width in
okay now it's just an area so I know
what the area of a semicircle is equal
to right it's half the area of a circle
which is PI R squared right so this
integral and this area is PI on to okay
it's not a crazy idea
it's just area that's what integration
is doing okay